[Musique]
nous nous trouvons actuellement place
saint médard au carrefour de la rue
manger de l'avenue des gobelins dans le
vieux quartier du bourg saint médard
dont l'artère principale est la rue
mouffetard
grâce à la brigade de l'année
d'où la belle hayden
m
il a élaboré le label
[Musique]
la rue mouffetard est une sorte de
marché permanent où affluent des
parisiens de tous les quartiers et de
toutes les classes sociales
ils s'y retrouvent au coude à coude en
rangs serrés dans une atmosphère un peu
débraillé bonnant
[Musique]
évidemment alors une seule est la
branche sauf à la batterie et
éventuellement sa faveur
je n'étais pas prêt
et voilà qu'on me l'a 63 en finale et
les commerçants sont souvent des enfants
du quartier qu'ils ont parfois débuté
modestement comme petits marchands à la
sauvette
c'est le cas de madame nini dont la mère
a commencé également comme marchande à
la sauvette est ce qu'elle entend vous
inviter ce quartier de la rue mouffetard
à la mi mai
oui pas longtemps j'y suis né à quoi
est-ce qu'elle ressemblait à ce moment
là la rue mouffetard bat toujours un peu
près commerçants de comme elle est
peut-être plus qu'a fait moins de métaux
le charcutier c'est un café avant tout
le temps - de boutique en boutique rue
jean commerce d'alimentation et vous vos
débuts et bam au début j'ai rendu à la
tirage est vendu d'abord chez ma tante
qui venait en face au 124 rue mouffetard
et après j'ai eu un tirage est vendu la
terrasse et après dans la rue daubenton
n'y avait pas de commerces y avait une
vie que dans six hausses qui est parti
alors la foncière va nous tient la
boutique francs là alors il ferait la
boutique et j'ai fait mes débuts avec
cette première boutique et après c'était
un marchand de papier peint à côté de
moi alors il a voulu vendre un petit
fruit alors j'ai pris je l'aï fait assez
et j'ai continué comme ça dans la rue et
je continue mon commerce
et maintenant vous avez maintenant je me
suis arrêté là
ouais ouais quand même beauté base on
est 6 ha oui c'est toute la rue de
l'alimentation coin la ramène ton est
devenu commerçant mais on l'a attiré le
monde parce qu'il n'y avait pas de
commerce avant mais après il ya eu le
monsieur l'air la ville ouverte ça met
beaucoup de monde aussi
emma peel voisine d'en face la russie
alors où ça lui fait une bonne ambiance
et puis la clientèle était pourtant bien
servi alors lu beaucoup de clients nous
travaille bien et maintenant votre
travail actuel en quoi est-ce que ça
consiste bon bah ouais le matin avec les
commis quoi je vois là trois heures
quatre heures salle et prend la saison
et puis on vient vers 7h alors aux
descendants de par villa on descend la
place côté ce qui a conduit à la ruine
on vient s'installer en empruntant ce
trajet vous ne vous doutez pas madame
n'est ni que vous réinventer une route
présentiel la voie romaine qui par la
rue saint-jacques la rue de la montagne
sainte-geneviève la rue descartes la rue
mouffetard reliait paris à lyon et à
l'italie la rue mouffetard c'était donc
la route du midi une route commerciale
qui attirait et retenaient les marchands
ce mur qui s'élève encore près de la
contrescarpe c'est le mur de philippe
auguste l'enceinte qui séparait paris du
bourg saint médard pour franchir cette
enceinte les marchands devaient
acquitter des taxes très lourde
aussi avant de passer l'octroi juste
avant de passer il essayer d'écouler
leurs marchandises dans les tavernes et
dans les maisons qui étaient situées en
dehors des murailles
c'est à dire précisément dans la rue
mouffetard il en résulte est tout un
marché clandestin qui se tenait dans la
rue et beaucoup de parisiens venaient en
fraude se ravitailler là parce que
c'était moins cher qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
oh
par cette même route d'italie ce ne sont
pas seulement les marchands qui ont
pénétré mais aussi les idées les
influences grecque romaine et chrétienne
ont laissé des traces durables dans la
rue mouffetard et le quartier latin nla
au nord de la rue mouffetard avec ces
lycées ces grandes écoles et ces foyers
d'étudiants
[Musique]
depuis la crise du logement d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'étudiants viennent chercher
un geste dans le quartier ils y trouvent
des logements économiques à proximité
des grandes écoles et il y trouve aussi
des restaurants populaires où l'on peut
manger à sa faim sans craindre de
dépenser trop d'argent
[Musique]
aspiré par ce véritable carrefour qu'est
la mouffe des étudiants de toutes races
viennent se fixer là comme ce jeune
tunisien que nous avons joint dans sa
chambre d'hôtel
[Musique]
vous êtes étudiant passionné d'art oui
je suis étudiant en lettres je prépare
un diplôme d'allemands ensuite
l'agrégation oui j'essaie de pousser
jusque là mais enfin je tenterai
toujours est-ce que c'est par hasard que
brève news installé rue mouffetard
oui tout à fait par hasard un copain y
habitent et puis il m'a cédé sa chambre
c'est une pratique assez courante il
faut dire et cette chambre est ce que
vous êtes content de l'invité c'est
commode pour vous oui un côté pratique
évident bien sûr c'est à quelques pas de
la sorbonne
c'est toujours le quartier latin la
périphérie immédiate du quartier latin
et puis c'est un marché mais dans ma
marche et quelquefois très bruyant mais
et tout est à portée de la main
et est ce que vous êtes en marge de ce
quartier ou bien ce que vous avez
l'impression de vous y être intégrée
nous j'ai songé quelquefois acquitté
mais maintenant il ya un côté
sentimental qui nous rattache à cette
rue là enfin la rue mouffetard l'amuhf
comme on dit c'est tout un monde
c'est tout un monde baroque chaotique un
carrefour de race le de civilisation est
évidemment moi même étudiant installé
plutôt dans le provisoire
j'essaie tout un climat intellectuel
enfin climat une atmosphère qui me
convient dans lequel je peux me
retrouver un quartier s'explique en
partie par sa situation par les autres
quartiers qui l'entourent or rien de ce
qui entoure la rue mouffetard ne lui
ressent il s'agit
au nord et à l'est de la place maubert
du jardin des plantes et de la halle aux
vins ou qu'il s'agisse au sud de
l'avenue des gobelins et du xiiie
arrondissement à tout cet environnement
la rue mouffetard résiste comme elle
peut ce qui la renforce dans son
originalité et la pousse à se définir
comme un véritable petit village
l'autobus 84 représente le lien entre ce
village et paris la grande
ben non monsieur il ya combien de temps
vous être solaires sur cette ligne
offert il ya bientôt cinq ans en octobre
est ce que les voyageurs qui prennent
l'autobus place de la contrescarpe sont
des habitués en général
le matin ce sont surtout les habitués
j'avais ce qu'ils prennent l'autobus à
6h30 qui vont jusqu'à champerret ensuite
ceux de 19h45 là ce sont des
fonctionnaires ils descendent à
bellechasse qui travaillent dans les
ministères
ensuite vous avez ceux de 20h45 la plus
employée de bureau
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
votre tapis sera présente un lien entre
le quartier le reste de paris oui
vraiment parce que la contrescarpe je
suis un petit peu comme une place de
province et ils prennent l'autobus pour
aller travailler à paris
il y avait là autrefois toute une
population ouvrière de tanner et de
tapissier groupe et le long du cours de
la bièvre et occupant tout l'est de la
rue mouffetard
[Musique]
il
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus que la look
cuir qui travaillent au ralenti et qui
va bientôt disparaître
le sel utilisée par les tanneurs à tous
corrodé jusqu'aux murs de la bâtisse
pourquoi ce bouleversement est bien
parce que le baron haussmann en 1865 à
creuser la rue mange en plein coeur de
ce quartier ouvrit les vieilles maisons
ont été détruites
toute la partie sud de la rue mouffetard
a été complètement rasée de la place
d'italie à saint médard sur 600 mètres
de long c'est à dire la moitié de sa
longueur totale
des immeubles se sont bâtis colons de la
nouvelle artère ils ont proliféré et ils
ont attiré une population nouvelle une
population bourgeois tu
c'est ainsi qu'une partie de la rue
mouffetard est devenue l'avenue des
gobelins une avenue bruyante et un
personnel qui contraste avec notre rue
mouffetard quelle opposition en effet
entre l'avenue son agitation trépidante
et la mouche ce qu'affi interdite aux
voitures ce quartier des piétons qui
sont les maîtres de la chose allez
monsieur gillot à 83 ans il habite rue
mouffetard depuis 1919 et il en connaît
la population mieux que personne la
population est composée en génial
à part les cas personne d'ouvriers de
dépit gentizon mais vous pourriez n'est
pas mieux j'ai le moindre est titré chez
renault doutent menuisier duc ouvreur du
plâtre eagle path les gens soient un peu
attaché un quartier pas mais j'ai dû
grille et il y en a beaucoup des deux
personnes très âgées
j'ai connu des jeunes gens je suis
arrivé dans le quartier y avait un tas à
l'école maintenant
ils ont 45 50 ans ils sont presque
grimpeur c'est comme on veut
si j'étais attachés à leur village comme
des gens sédentaires ils sont attachés
de sorte que leurs quartiers en fête
c'est vrai ils ne sortent plus de leur
quartier tout se passe comme s'il
voulait préserver dans leurs murs une
vie plus humaine à une échelle réduite
tout est petit rue mouffetard et dans
leur cour et les habitants entretiennent
un misérable petit jardin qui leur donne
une apparence de verdure il y en a des
jardins des pots de fleurs et des vieux
arbres dans les cours intérieures de la
rue mouffetard madame labouré
comment se fait-il madame labouret que
vous ayez un petit jardin fond de la
cour et bien en fait cette maison qui
est vieille de trois siècles et plus
même était et son soleil et ma foi on y
mettait dans cette cour un tas de
détritus de vieilles affaires qui ne
servaient pas et la fois que nous avions
les maçons dans la maison jeu qui
faisait des réparations j'ai profité
pour leur demander s'ils pourraient pas
me faire un petit rond pour faire un
jardin et ma foi ils ont été très
gentils melon fait je suis donc allé au
quai aux fleurs acheter des fleurs est
ici en ce moment si y'a pas grand chose
mais elle était voyez-vous le garnissant
avec des géraniums ou des bégonias ce
qui agrémente beaucoup ce point qui est
sans soleil et ma foi les locataires
sont très contents parce que ça leur
donne un petit air de jardin des plantes
sont fait dire un plus petit c'est un
peu pour toutes ces raisons qu'il flotte
dans la rue mouffetard une atmosphère de
liberté et de fantaisie assez
exceptionnel
[Musique]
la contrée spa comme les clans chardon
se vendront place de la contrescarpe il
claque des talons
ils ont dévié je lai l'air
main dans leur poche je trouvais la
saône la contrescarpe les clochards
danse dans les t4 à beauvais 4 à aulnoye
rivel vautours les pistes aux bières
fraîches ou vin chaud mais le vent
balaie le gie
sur le toit des maisons et tourner le
noir rapport règne au laboratoire et
tourner le noir l'arabe et le breton ça
la contrescarpe tour dans la musique du
vent ce soit les fait danser et le
dernier passe on passe d'un pas pressé
puis le car de la police sans sirène ni
klaxon en parle sur le clochard
clocheton privilégier les pauvres
passeront la nuit au violon
mais en contre et stade d'autres pros
charte armes tombent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autrefois le cabaret du cheval d'or
était une mercerie le père léon et son
épouse ont fermé leurs magasins pour
ouvrir ce cabaret ou suc et sert son
leur tour de chant ses desserts qui sont
devenus des citoyens d'adoption de
l'amour encore un exemple de cet aspect
méridionale monsieur gilbert qui était
libre et rue descartes a transformé un
beau jour son magasin en académie des
guitares et depuis il reçoit dans sa
cave qui date du xiiie siècle
des artistes comme christian aubin
mon
on
[Musique]
m
chez la mère solange et tourne fort
les artistes fauchait trouve la table
mise et le repas gratuit
la mère solange n'hésite pas à chanter
et elle possède un répertoire terrifiant
de chansons de corps de gars c'est là
que jacques douai a débuté en
s'accompagnant à la guitare il y a dix
[Musique]
je suis un autre homme je ne me
reconnais pas là dieu ma petite maison
on établit ma poire mais pour devaux
meklouche la maison pour tous est un peu
le centre qui cristallise âgées sens
artistique du quartier un petit
imprimeur ce qui est découvert un jour
un talent de peintre
d'autres s'y exprime par le théâtre ce
sur une scène exit bien surtout que là
j'en parle
il a fait 6 mais tant pis je veux
montrer du doigt
l'atmosphère bohème et artistes de la
rue mouffetard a engendré un certain
nombre de vocations d'autodidacte ainsi
cet homme accueillant que tout le monde
connaît sous le nom de l'ap et lapins
oui bonjour les amis
et si vous êtes les bienvenus aude où va
l'eau - férié ici à la mouche faire nous
subissons les lois de ce fils a dit de
l'hospitalité c'est une loi immuable
alors ça vous chez nous tous les
déclasser les gens qui sont arriérés un
peu de la vie
1 alors nous essayons de les remettre
dans le circuit la vie à condition
qu'ils ne veuillent pas les bras palmer
l'emmental mais c'est gore en fait dans
le circuit de la vie recours à leurs
travaux préférentiels si vous voulez un
et nous sommes heureux c'est le goût
très jeunes voudraient changer quartier
pour rien au monde
c'est un quartier tous hier
d'intellectuels je ne peux l'apprendre
malgré que je n'ai jamais été candidat
aux vaches au mais dans ce cas de ce
quartier nous à perdre nous nous nous
éduquons perpétuellement le qualifiant
d' étudiants perpétuelle l'ambiance est
tous hier d'extraordinaire ici c'est le
quartier de plus un des sit in et de
paris de quartier olé les automobilistes
sont pas naître car les trottoirs
n'existe pas préférentiellement
voici donc la rue mouffetard 600 m 2 rue
sur lesquels s'entassent 9000 habitants
quatre mille logements dont 2500
seulement ont l'eau et 268 une baignoire
ou une douche
grâce au génie du bricolage des français
certains appartements deviennent plus qu
habitable et les mètres cubes
disponibles sont utilisés au mieux
mais songez que sur 206 immeuble 149 ont
été construits avant 1860 et ont aussi
beaucoup menace-t-il ruines il y a dans
la rue mouffetard près de 40 hôtels
meublés dans l'ensemble plus que modeste
dans ce cadre étroit et misérable chacun
essaie de reconstituer une atmosphère
personnel
dites-moi petits bobos quand êtes-vous
arrivé ici ici mes copains et elle a
déjà su qsr habitait l'hôtel et m'ont
signalé que le chameau et est allouée
sous les toits au troisième je suis venu
voir mais au départ le locataire et que
c'était à moi faisait de la cuisine ou
je sais pas quoi
la chambre était tout noir plein de
fumée j'ai hésité un peu et puis quand
j'avais vraiment pas dans le jeu mais je
suis resté j'ai toujours peint j'ai
passé les bijoux à désinfecter à
nettoyer parce qu'il y avait des petites
bêtes il y avait des puits alors j'ai
installé du tissu des filets de pêche
fait tout ce que j'avais quoi j'ai
essayé de faire un petit chez moi et
puis je me suis installé et parfois j'y
suis depuis et combien payez-vous je
paie 5000 francs par mois mais sans le
chauffage et onu est allée des
radiateurs mais je voulais pas attendre
j'ai essayé d'installer des machines
électriques mais pour l'électricité je
suis je suis limité quoi j'ai un voltage
à ne pas dépasser et je le dépasse avec
mes trois en poule c qui fait que
parfois ça sorte
si je vous rachetez 3e poule et ça
m'arrive parfois je j'ai une bougie en
car pour nous c'est pareil d'ailleurs si
les voisins du dessous ouvrent leur
robinet c'est fini j'ai plutôt l'absence
ou l'étroitesse des logements a une
conséquence toute naturelle le rôle
important que jouent les bistrots seul
endroit où l'on puisse se réunir pour ça
que je crois jamais situeront les gens
voient
ils ont tourné quant aux enfants ils ne
vont pas encore au bistrot mais ils sont
livrés à eux mêmes sans condamner à
vivre dehors soit aux arènes de lutèce
tout proche soit dans la rue en bande
[Musique]
leur jeu se déroule est ce un symbole
sur l'emplacement de l'ancienne prison
sainte pélagie
[Musique]
que deviendront-ils ses enfants précoces
et débrouillard qui échangent et revente
des illustrés pour se faire un peu
d'argent de poche et apprennent déjà
suire les représentants de la loi
[Musique]
ainsi la rue mouffetard n'est pas
seulement un quartier romantique et
pleine crise c'est aussi un îlot un
salut faut-il rasés alors toutes les
rues alentour commencent à disparaître à
s'effondrer sous la poussée des
quartiers avoisinants
des immeubles modernes s'élève
maintenant à la place des taudis sur les
lieux où se tenait le marché aux puces
de la rue saint médard la rue ortolan la
rue gracieuse des grands bâtiments
anonymes se dresse maintenant que fuir
on s'en doute car les loyers y seront
chères les quelque 2000 ouvriers du
quartier
non
[Musique]
des magasins plus important s'installe
et des commerçants alapage com monsieur
masure tailleur et marchands de tissus
transforme peu à peu la rue mouffetard
monsieur masure est revenu tout exprès
des sports d'hiver notre enquête nous
lui avons demandé si la rue mouffetard
était semblable à ce qu'elles étaient
après la guerre de 1914 nos noms elle a
bien changé autrefois elle avait une
mauvaise réputation due à la proximité
de la place maubert des bals musette et
des clochards qu'il y avait mais tout
cela a bien changé
il y a eu évidemment la crise du
logement est certes un élément très bien
comme des gens qui ont des professions
libérales sont venus dans ce village que
l'on appelle la rue mouffetard
indépendamment de cela il y a également
des ouvriers des gens moyens et sont
très bien qu'ils habitent dans de tout
petits logements mais qui sont des gens
très agréables en plus et bien ma foi il
ya une évolution
la rue a changé un peu parce que les
magasins se sont modifiées ce sont
embellies et tout le monde vient faire
son marché et grâce à lui
ma foi on a
une clientèle qui vient évidemment de la
rive gauche du boulevard saint-michel de
la rue soufflot et il voit ici de jolies
choses ce qui nous permet d'avoir
également une clientèle très belle est
ce là vraiment l'avenir de la rue
mouffetard
que restera-t-il d'elle lorsque le
progrès technique lui aura donné un
visage tout neuf
[Musique]